obviously
coming from your background talk about
what's the biggest l you've taken in the
streets man
because i you know everyone's i mean not
everyone but you know you
dabble in that world you know that
sometimes you take a l sometimes a
package get lost in the mail
or so you know whatever it is yeah one
time see i lost like
250 [ __ ] this year i lost like 180
but i don't trip about it so you lost
250 000
one time at one time what what okay give
us as much of the circumstances you can
give this without snitching on yourself
just some [ __ ] getting lost he got lost
that's what
he got lost so i guess you know what i'm
saying but
we got [ __ ] back from people don't want
to hear you complain yeah bouncing back
from a 250 000
l brush that's that's that's rough what
how did you like the 180 this year what
was that same situation
not some there's some some other [ __ ]
damn
that's some man i got someone broke into
my car this year
yeah and took 15 000 in cash out of my
trunk bro while i was in a notary
yeah that's it that [ __ ] hurt they hit
different though you know
i'll be looking at it like i don't care
if i lose a thousand or a hundred
thousand that [ __ ] still hit the same
yeah especially if someone takes it from
you bro yeah like a guy if you want to
kill somebody
yeah like god damn like
but i guess you know bigger the risk of
the reward but one thing about me
like when i always lose that type of
money like
even when you know because me my mama
recruits
i tell my mom doing everything but i
won't be like man every time you always
bounce back from me
and i always like i lost i remember i
took a big air
and then that's when uh arnold called me
it was like endoscope want to sign you
and he told me to know how yeah yeah so
every time i always take a loss i'll
bounce back from like
god who blessed me was way bigger than
what i lost it's like you took the l and
then you signed an interscope right
after
exactly like you know what i ain't even
tripping yeah and that was one of the
biggest losses i
ever took in life like i always probably
lost like a little 30 here right right
yeah
yeah yeah but that was the biggest loss
and then right after that i'd say like a
week later
and i had a show like when it happened i
had a show in virginia
man i was about to go home like i ain't
even want to do this [ __ ] up your whole
[ __ ] move
man that [ __ ] [ __ ] your whole vibe up
like we got girls and all
around i'm like man [ __ ] these like i
ain't even thinking about that [ __ ]
yo what's crazy is like the reason why i
really really resonated with baby's
music early on was because
i felt like he did such a good job of
talking about
selling weed like the packs and [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like i feel like
i'm talking about even before that
obviously sugar is huge but even before
that like i like
i was like yeah i've never heard anybody
rap about selling weed
that i'm i could relate to more than
like burner you know somebody like that
but yeah shout out to burnley
but he would but baby told me that he
used to sell
the uh he would used to vacuum seal up
rabbit food
rubber full yeah right which is
dangerous you get caught slipping
did you ever dabble in any sort of that
no i ain't never did i did screw it up
in this
i ain't never like i ain't really been
into that world like
not knocking somebody who'd do it but no
i do straight up business i ain't never
really had to
rob it for this yeah cause i was like
damn bro like
i'm glad you're still here yeah yeah you
made it through it
cause that kind of [ __ ] man you you
sounds like rabbit food with the wrong
peoples
they gonna kill you in south carolina i
don't know about knuckling but you would
have got your ass about it even right
now
especially how big he is it wouldn't
work